This is Hidden Brain, I'm Shankar Vedantam. This episode explores explicit themes. If you're listening with small kids, you may want to save this for later. Parties were huge, hookups were huge. Everyone just seemed to be doing everything with each other. And yet I always kind of felt like I wasn't doing it right. There are certain ideas that send the media into a panic. One of them is hook-up culture.
这里是《隐藏的大脑》，我是尚卡尔·韦丹塔姆。本期节目将探讨一些露骨的话题。如果你正和幼小的孩子一起收听，或许可以留到以后再听。派对规模很大，约炮也很普遍。每个人似乎都在和所有人发生关系。然而，我总是觉得自己好像没有做对。有些观念会让媒体陷入恐慌。其中之一就是约炮文化。
College students are quote unquote, hooking up. Hook-up, hook-up. Hook-up. Hook-up culture. Yeah, I wonder where people can just be sitting in a cafe and find someone to hook up with. Are you buying this? Kids are more sexual than ever.
大学生们正在“约炮”，所谓“约炮”。约炮，约炮。约炮。约炮文化。是的，我很纳闷人们怎么能随随便便坐在咖啡馆里就找到人约炮。你相信这个吗？现在的年轻人比以往任何时候都更具性意识。
Stories about casual sex on college campuses have long been a staple of cable news, but the truth is more nuanced. College students are actually not having more sex than their parents did a generation ago, but something has changed. Not just in what students do or what they don't do, but in how they think. I have students who have had sex many times drunk, but have never held someone's hand. If casual sex was taboo a generation ago, emotional intimacy has become taboo today. It's something to be explored in secret. Maybe even something to be ashamed about. I think it feels bad to be used, but I think the alternative is that nobody wants to use you and I think
关于大学校园里随意性行为的故事长期以来一直是电视新闻的主要内容，但事实要复杂得多。事实上，现在的大学生并不比他们上一代的父母拥有更多的性生活，但确实有些东西改变了。不仅是学生的所作所为改变了，他们的思想也变了。我有学生在喝醉酒的情况下发生过很多次性关系，却从来没有牵过别人的手。如果说随意性行为在上一代人眼中还是禁忌，那么今天，情感亲密反而成了禁忌。这是一个需要秘密探索的东西。甚至可能是某种让人感到羞耻的事。我认为被人利用感觉很糟糕，但我想替代方案是根本没有人想利用你，我觉得
that that's worse. Lisa Wade is a sociologist at Occidental College. In her book, American Hookup, the new culture of sex on campus, Lisa interviews college students and finds that hookup culture has a complex set of social rules. She says these rules threaten the emotional well-being of students, those who embrace the culture, and those who want nothing to do with it. Lisa, thanks for joining me on Hidden Brain today. Thank you so much for having me. We spoke with several students in your book, Lisa, and we're going to hear from them in
那才是更糟糕的。莉莎·韦德是西方学院的社会学家。在她的书《美国约炮：校园性爱新文化》中，莉莎采访了大学生，发现约炮文化有一套复杂的社会规则。她说，这些规则威胁着学生的情感健康——无论是那些拥抱这种文化的人，还是那些对此退避三舍的人。莉莎，谢谢你今天做客《隐藏的大脑》。非常感谢邀请我。莉莎，我们在你的书中采访了几位学生，在这期节目中我们将听到他们的声音。
this conversation. One of the things that kept coming up was that there's no one definition of what hooking up actually is. It can mean a variety of things from making out to having sex, but for all the ambiguity, there does seem to be a clear set of guidelines when it comes to how students should hook up. You know, it's funny because the ideology around hookups is that they're supposed to be spontaneous. And the fact is that there's a pretty rigid set of rules
不断浮现的一个问题是，对于“什么是约炮”，其实并没有一个统一的定义。从卿卿我我到发生性关系，它可以意味着各种各样的事情。但尽管存在种种模糊性，在学生们究竟该如何约炮这件事上，似乎确实有一套清晰的准则。你知道，这挺搞笑的，因为关于约炮的意识形态是它们应该是自发的。但事实是，关于约炮是如何发生的，有一套相当死板的规则。
for how hookups happen. Many of them, probably most of them start at parties where there's drinking. And the way to initiate it is through dancing. So usually in these heterosexual encounters, women will initiate the dancing by going into the middle of the dance floor. And then in a very sort of gender-traditional way, hope that someone picks her and comes up along behind her. Sometimes the woman doesn't even know who is behind her,
其中许多，可能绝大多数都始于有酒精的派对。发起的方式是通过跳舞。通常在这些异性恋遭遇中，女性会通过走到舞池中央来发起舞蹈。然后以一种非常传统的性别方式，希望有人选中她并从她身后走过来。有时女性甚至不知道身后是谁，
which creates a conundrum because part of hooking up is trying to hook up with people that your friends approve of and think are like a good catch. And so often she's dancing, someone comes up behind her, and then what she'll do is she'll look across the circle to one of her girlfriends and try to get some indication as to whether or not she should continue. Let's talk some more about this idea that hookups are a way to win the approval of your friends.
这就产生了一个难题，因为约炮的一部分是试图和那些你的朋友认可并且认为是个“好对象”的人约炮。所以通常她跳着舞，有人从身后走过来，然后她会做的是，她会隔着人群看一眼她的某个女友，试图得到某种暗示，表明自己是否应该继续下去。我们再来聊聊这个观点，即约炮是赢得朋友认可的一种方式。
You're saying that some hookups move you up the social packing order and others move you down? Hookups are decidedly not about finding any sort of romantic connection and suggesting that it should be or that one is doing it for that reason is tantamount to breaking a social rule. They're often not so much about pleasure in particular for women. They're very much about status. So the idea is to be able to brag about or having sort of gotten someone who other people might also wish they could have
你是说有些约炮能让你在社交阶梯上往上爬，而另一些则让你往下掉？约炮绝对不是为了寻找任何形式的浪漫连结，暗示它应该是或者有人是为了这个原因去做这件事，等同于打破社会规则。它们通常与快乐无关，对女性而言尤其如此。它们很大程度上关乎地位。所以这个想法是能够吹嘘或者说搞到了一个别人可能也希望自己能搞到的人，
gotten. So it's all about being able to say I got that guy over there or that person that everyone's looking for, I managed to be the one who hooked up with him tonight. One of the unspoken rules to talk about in hook-up culture is that it's really important that the hook-up be meaningless. One of the young men we spoke with described a situation that almost seems Kafka-esque. We really like each other, but she would not have sex with me. But I also knew that she was working up with someone. And this was such a confusing concept, which is that people will have sex with people that they don't like,
所以这完全是为了能够说：我搞定了那边的那个家伙，或者那个所有人都在寻找的人，我今晚设法成了跟他约炮的人。谈论约炮文化时的一个潜规则是，约炮毫无意义这一点非常重要。我们采访过的一个年轻男子描述了一种近乎卡夫卡式的场景。我们真的很喜欢彼此，但她不肯跟我发生性关系。但我也知道她一直在跟别人约炮。这是一个极其令人困惑的概念，那就是人们会跟自己不喜欢的人发生性关系，
but won't have sex with people that they do like. And of course, what does young man is saying? He can't understand why this young woman who likes him and that he likes is having sex with someone else whom she doesn't like but won't have sex with him. What the students are confronted with is this artificial binary between careless and careful sex. On the one hand, we have this idea that when we get into romantic relationships, we're supposed to be loving and kind, and the sex that happens
却不会跟自己喜欢的人发生性关系。当然，这个年轻人说的是什么？他无法理解为什么这个喜欢他、他也喜欢的年轻女子会和另一个她不喜欢的人发生性关系，却不肯和他发生性关系。展现在学生们面前的是“随性”与“谨慎”性爱之间这种人造的二元对立。一方面，我们有一种观念，认为当我们陷入恋爱关系时，我们应该充满爱意和善良，而在那种关系中发生的性行为是高度承诺的。另一方面，我们有随意性行为这个概念，它与前者截然相反。这意味着，一旦随意性行为摆上台面，所有伴随恋爱关系而来的善意都被视为“出局”的。
in those kinds of relationships is very committed. And on the other hand, we have this concept of casual sex, which is the opposite of that. And that means that all of the kindnesses that go along with romantic relationships are considered off-script, once casual sex is on the table. So if two students are going to hook up together and they want it to be meaningless, then they have to do some work to make sure that both they and everyone else understands that we're over in this meaningless camp and not this powerfully meaningful one. And so to sort of
因此，如果两个学生想要约炮，并且希望这毫无意义，那么他们就必须做一些工作，以确保他们自己和所有人都明白：我们是在这个“毫无意义”的阵营，而不是那个“具有强大意义”的阵营。因此，为了向自己和他人证明或向他人展示它是毫无意义的，他们必须找到一种方法来“表演”毫无意义。这不是自动发生的。他们通过以下方式做到这一点，例如，确保自己喝醉了，或者在约炮时显得喝醉了。
convince themselves and other people or to show them tells another people that it was meaningless, they have to find a way to perform meaningless. It's not automatic. And they do that by, for example, making sure that they're drunk, or they appear to be drunk when they hook up. So my students actually speak in pretty hushed tones
所以我的学生其实是用一种非常低声下气的语气来谈论清醒时的性爱。清醒时的性爱是非常严肃的，但如果学生们喝了酒，这就有助于传递出一个信息：这毫无意义。另一种方式是确保他们不会跟同一个人约炮太多次。所以如果他们真的对对方没有浪漫的好感，那就约一次，顶多两次，然后就断了。第三件他们为了确立这种无意义感而必须做的事，就是在事后给那个人在他们的生活中“降级”。
about sober sex. Sober sex is very serious, but if the students have been drinking, then that helps send the message that it's meaningless. Another way is to make sure that they don't hook up with the same person very many times. So if they really don't like the person in a romantic way, just hook up once, maybe twice, and then cut it off. And then the third thing they have to do to try to establish this meaninglessness is to sort of give that person a demotion in their lives afterward.
无意义的概念意味着我们也不应该以任何方式在乎那个人。你在书中谈到，尽管你知道，在大学校园里关于约炮的讨论无处不在，但这并不一定反映了实际发生的情况。因此，人们对学生的性活跃度感到非常焦虑，但事实证明，从大多数标准来看，他们的性活跃度并不比他们的父母在他们这个年纪时更高。
The idea that it's meaningless means that we're also not supposed to care about that person at all, and in any way. You're talking the book about how even though, you know, talk about hookups is ubiquitous on college campuses, that doesn't necessarily reflect how much of it is actually going on. So there's a lot of consternation about students' sexual activity, but it turns out that they are no more sexually
平均每个毕业的大四学生在四年里约炮八次。也就是说一个学期一次，其中有一半的约炮对象是他们之前已经约过的人。事实上，大约三分之一的学生在整个大学生涯中连一次约炮都没有。但这并不意味着他们没有被这些关于他们“应该做什么”的强有力观念所包围。这也不意味着他们能够改变同龄人与他们互动的方式，或者改变高等教育运作的方式。
active by most measures than their parents were at their age. The average graduating senior has hooked up eight times in four years. So that's once a semester, and half of those hookups are with someone that they've hooked up with before. And in fact, about a third of students won't hook up even a single time their entire college career. But that doesn't mean that they're not surrounded by these really powerful ideas about what they should be doing. And it doesn't mean that they can change
因此，尽管校园约炮文化可能确实得到了少数狂热分子的支持，但你指出的其中一点是，这些人往往来自那些在社会中历来拥有巨大权力和特权的群体。大约15%的学生真心实意地享受约炮文化。它给了他们大学生活中最想要的东西。研究表明，如果你问那些学生——他们是约炮最多的学生——如果你问他们是否玩得开心，
how their peers interact with them or the way in which higher education works. So even though campus hook-up culture might actually be something that is endorsed by a relatively small number of people who are enthusiasts, one of the points you make is that these are people who often come from groups who have traditionally had a lot of power and privilege in society. About 15% of students really, really truly enjoy hook-up culture. It gives them exactly what they want out of college. And studies show that if you ask those students, and they're the students that are hooking up the most, if you ask them if they're having a good time,
他们会说是的，我相信他们。大约三分之一的学生彻底退出了。其余的学生则处于中间某个位置，他们对随意性行为持矛盾态度，但如果你看看那些最享受约炮文化的学生，这些人不成比例地是异性恋、白人、来自中上阶层或富裕背景、男性、身体健全、
they say yes, and I believe them. About a third of students are completely opted out. The rest of the students are somewhere in the middle, and they're ambivalent about the idea of casual sex, but if you look at the students who enjoy hook-up culture the most, those students are disproportionately going to be heterosexual, white, come from an upper middle class or wealthy background, they're going to be male, they're going to be able-bodied,
符合传统审美。那么对于少数族裔或LGBTQ群体的人来说，情况有什么不同呢？少数族裔面临着白人学生所没有的各种复杂问题。这在很大程度上取决于我们所关注的具体交叉性。因此，一些少数族裔比其他少数族裔更容易被白人学生接受。非洲裔美国男性和亚裔女性通常被认为是性感和充满异国情调的，而亚裔男性和非洲裔美国女性则不那么受欢迎。
conventionally attractive. And how is this different for racial minorities or people from the LGBT community? Racial minorities face all kinds of complicated problems that white students don't. And it depends a lot kind of on what particular intersection we're looking at. So some racial minorities are embraced by white students more than others. So African-American men and Asian women are usually considered hot and exotic, whereas Asian men and African-American women are considered less so.
因此，这很大程度上取决于学生所处的种族、性别和阶层的交叉点。但总体而言，出于推力和拉力的双重原因，我们看到少数族裔的约炮率较低。所以，一部分原因是由于种族主义和特权白人的色情等级制度，他们被“推”了出去。但他们也往往被“拉”回来，因为少数族裔更有可能有宗教信仰。他们喝酒较少，为了考上大学可能一开始就必须表现得无可挑剔。因此，少数族裔在约炮文化中并不那么受欢迎，他们也觉得这种文化没那么吸引人。
So it very much depends on what intersection of race, gender, and class too, that students are sitting in. But overall, we see lower rates of hooking up among racial minorities for both push and pull reasons. So, part of it is they're pushed out because of racism and an erotic hierarchy that privileges whiteness. But they also tend to get pulled out because racial minorities are more likely to be religious. They drink less alcohol, they maybe had to be more squeaky clean to get into college to begin with. So racial minorities aren't as welcome in hookup culture and they also don't find it as attractive.
那LGBTQ群体呢？对于不认为自己是异性恋的学生来说——其实我们在这方面还需要做更多的研究——目前看来发生的情况是，在小型校园里，或者在人们不太敢出柜的校园里，对于那些不认为自己是异性恋或双性恋的学生来说，并没有一个替代的约炮场景。而确实存在的约炮场景又高度异性恋化。在这些情况下，学生参与其中就要自行承担风险，要么在行为或态度上面临恐同症的风险，要么就去校外寻找。
And what about the LGBT community? For students who don't identify as heterosexual and we actually still need to do more research on this, but what it seems to be happening is that on small campuses or campuses where people aren't very out, there's not an alternative hookup scene for students who don't identify as heterosexual or bisexual. And the hookup scene that does exist is hyper heterosexualized. And in those cases, students participate at their own risk, risking homophobia in either
这就是为什么Grindr进入大学校园的时间远早于Tinder，因为许多被识别为非异性恋的学生正在使用它在校外寻找约炮对象。广告回来后，我将问问莉莎关于约炮文化对年轻人情感生活的影响。请继续收听。这里是《隐藏的大 脑》，我是尚卡尔·韦丹塔姆。有些人提出的一个观点——这包括左翼女权主义者和右翼自由主义者——是约炮可以是解放性的。
behavior or attitude, or they go off campus. And that is why Grindr hit college campuses way earlier than Tinder did because a lot of students who identified as non-heterosexual were using it to find hookups off campus. When we come back, I'm going to ask Lisa about the effects of hookup culture on the emotional lives of young people. Stay with us. This is Hidden Brain, I'm Shankar Vedantam. One argument that some make and this includes feminists on the left and libertarians on the right is that hookups can be liberating.
人们有机会进行实验、尝试新事物，他们被赋能去发现自己的偏好。但我们采访过的一位学生莉莎说，有时听起来像赋能的东西，往往会变成别的东西。我确实有过这样的经历：一旦约炮开始了，一些期望就会开始显露出来，而且它们的态度并不友善。你知道，这不是，这不是一场关于“嘿，你愿意试试这个吗”或者“嘿，你知道的，我真的很喜欢我的伴侣对我这样做”的对话。它更像是“你现在就要这么做”。
People have a chance to experiment, try new things, they're empowered to discover their preferences. But one of the students we spoke with Lisa said that what sometimes starts out sounding like empowerment often becomes something else. I did have experiences where the expectations once the hook-up had already started would start to come out and they wouldn't come out kindly. You know, it's not, it wasn't a conversation of, hey are you willing to try this or hey, you know, I really like it when my partner does this to me. It would be a little bit more of, you're going to do this now.
所以莉莎，约炮文化和某些人所说的“强奸文化”有关系吗？是的，我认为约炮文化就是一种强奸文化，因为它促成了并纵容了那些会转化为性侵犯的行为。你能详细谈谈吗？我的意思是，有些狂热分子基本上会说，我们只是在行使我们的自由选择。我们不受上一代人可能受到的规范的束缚，人们进行实验、尝试新事物、弄清楚自己究竟是谁，这有什么错？所以我们在大学校园里看到约炮文化的部分原因可以追溯到性革命和女权运动。
So Lisa, does hook up culture have anything to do with what some people would call rape culture? Yes, I would argue that hook up culture is a rape culture in that it facilitates and excuses behaviors that translate into sexual assault. Can you expand on that? I mean, there are enthusiasts who would basically say, you know, we're just exercising, you know, our free choice. We're not constrained by the norms that might have hindered a prior generation, what's wrong with people experimenting, trying new things, figuring out who they really are? So part of the reason we see hookup culture
女权运动希望女性在性以及其他方面获得两样东西。他们希望女性有机会去做男性做的事，并体现男性的特质和兴趣。他们希望所有人都能注意到，女性一直以来在做的事情以及人们认为她们拥有的特质和兴趣同样具有价值。而我们实际上只得到了其中的一半。因此，女权主义者成功地说服了美国。在很大程度上，女性应该被允许做男性做的事，甚至拥有男性的特质。但我们从未真正去重视那些我们定义为女性化的东西。
on college campuses can be traced back to the sexual revolution in the women's movement. And the women's movement wanted two things for women, both sexually and otherwise. They wanted women to have the opportunity to do the things that men do and to embody masculine traits and interests. And they wanted everyone to sit up and notice that the things women had been doing all along and the traits and interests
因此，今天在美国长大的年轻女性，她会被——大多数父母不是这样的，但大多数父母会鼓励他们的女儿将男性的特质和兴趣融入她的性格中。甚至会鼓励她这样做，并且当她这样做时，或许会比她融入女性性格特质时给予更多的奖励。因此，当她还是个孩子时喜欢玩工程玩具，我们会感到兴奋；当她选择运动而不是啦啦队时，我们会感到兴奋；当她决定
that they were believed to have were also valuable. And we really only got half of that. So the feminists succeeded in convincing America. For the most part, the women should be allowed to do what men do and even have masculine traits. But we never really got around to valuing the things that we define as feminine. So a young woman who's growing up in America today is going to, she's going to be told by
主修物理而不是教育时，我们会感到兴奋。所以女性一直在接收到这样的信息。如果她们稍加注意的话，就会非常清楚地发现，正如他们所说，“行为规矩的女性很少创造历史”，当我们表现得像我们认为的典型男性那样时，我们会奖励你，我们认为这太棒了。因此，当她们来到校园时，这就是她们试图做的事情，校园里的许多女性决定以她们因在生活中做其他事情而受到奖励的相同方式来对待性，这不应该让我们任何人感到惊讶。
most, not all parents are like this, but most parents are going to encourage their daughters to mix in masculine traits and interests into her personality. And they're even going to encourage her to do so, and perhaps reward her more so when she does that than then when she incorporates feminine personality traits. So we're excited when she likes to play with engineering toys when she's a kid, and we're excited when she chooses sports over cheerleading, and we're excited that she decides
带着这种“应该做的事”、被解放的方式就是表现得像我所认为的典型男性那样的想法。所以你知道，尽管有很多人确实说约炮可以是解放性的，但我们采访过的一位年轻女性说，她实际上觉得有点被困住了。我认为女孩在被利用时是心知肚明的，而且我认为被利用感觉很糟糕，但我想替代方案是没人想利用你，这意味着你没有和任何人约炮，我认为那更糟糕。
to major in physics instead of education. And so women have been getting this message. If they're paying any attention at all, it's very clear that, as they say, well-'re paying any attention at all, it's very clear that, as they say, well-behaved women rarely make history, we reward you, we think it's great, when you act like we think a stereotypical man does. So then when they get to campus, that's what they try to do, and it should surprise none of us that many women on campus decide to approach sexuality the same way they've
莉莎，这个问题听起来有点让人心碎，因为听起来这位年轻女性的意思是，她意识到自己觉得正在被利用，但她觉得除了被利用别无选择。对于那些并不真正享受随意性行为的女性来说，在约炮文化中并没有太多好的选择，当然也有一些人是享受的。但对其他人来说，她们基本上面临两种选择。一种是她们不参与任何性行为，这也意味着永远无法与任何人建立任何形式的恋爱关系。
been rewarded for approaching everything else in their lives. With this idea of the thing to do, the way to be liberated is to act in the way I think a stereotypical man might. So you know, while there are lots of people who do say that hookups can be liberating, one of the young women we spoke with said she actually feels a little trapped. I think girls know when they're being used and I think it feels bad to be used but I think the alternative is that nobody wants to use you and that means that you're not
另一种是和一个伴侣度过这段时期，即约炮期，怀着在另一端能成为那个人的女朋友的希望。校园里的双重标准有些不同。过去，男性拥有把女性归入两类之一的权力：好女孩或坏女孩。如果女性只是，引用原话，“规矩行事”，她大概能留在好女孩阵营，尽管这没有保证。但今天，男性依然拥有将女性归入这些群组的权力，但他们基本上把所有女性——无论如何都是他们正在约炮的所有女性——都归入了坏女孩阵营。
talking up with anybody and I think that that's worse. So there's something heartbreaking about that question Lisa because it sounds like what this young woman is saying is that she recognizes that she feels she is being used, but she feels she doesn't have a choice but to be used. There are not a lot of good options for women in hook-up culture that don't truly enjoy casual sex, and there are some that do. But for the rest of them, they're kind of faced with two options. One is that they don't participate in any sexual
然后，在某个时刻拥有决定权的权力是：哦，我和你约炮一段时间了，现在我决定我喜欢你，现在我要开始尊重你并把你当平等的人对待。如果一个女性想要一段在某个时刻她会被尊重并作为平等者对待的关系，那么她就必须经历这样一段时期：在那个时期她并没有得到这些对待。因此，女性的选择要么是完全退出约炮文化，要么就是让自己暴露在这样一段时期中——在这一时期她受到不尊重对待，寄希望于它能在另一端转化为更好的结果。
activity at all, which also means never getting into any sort of romantic relationship with someone. And the other is passing through this period with a person, the hook-up period, with the hopes of coming out the other end as that person's girlfriend. And there's something different about the double standard on college campuses. It used to be that men would have the power to kind of put women into one of two categories, the good girl or the bad girl. And if women just, quote unquote, behaved herself, she could probably stay in the good girl camp, although there's no guarantee. But today, men still have this power to put women into one of these groups, but they put basically all women into the bad girl group, all women they're hooking up with anyway.
我们采访过的一位女性实际上描述了一种非常类似于这种情况的处境，但也描述了她所面临的一个两难困境，那就是：即便当她喜欢一个和她约炮过的人时，约炮文化的规则也阻止她向对方说出她真正想要的东西。那种跟女孩约炮后就不放手的家伙。人们通常不会谈论这个。相比之下，那种约了一次就爱上你、对你死缠烂打的女孩。那个疯狂的女孩。是的，有这种说法。
And then, have the power at some point to decide, oh I've been hooking up with you for a while, now I'm going to decide that I like you, and now I'm going to treat you with respect and as an equal. If a woman wants a relationship where at some point she'll be retreated with respect and as an equal, then she has to go through this period where she's not those things. So women's options are either opt out of hook-up culture altogether or expose herself to this period where she's treated disrespectfully in the hopes that it translates into something better on the other end. One of the women we talked with actually describes a situation very much like this, but also describes a dilemma which she faced,
而我们是如此迫切地不想让自己看起来像那样。所以，当你和某个你实际上真的很喜欢、真的很想和他在一起的人约炮，然后他们没有给你回短信。于是就结束了。听起来那是个糟糕透顶的处境，因为你经历约炮文化是为了试图找到一段关系，但规则却要求你实际上不能开口索要。对的。对的。
which is even when she likes someone that she's hooked up with, the rules of hook-up culture prevent her from telling the other person what she actually wants. That kind of guy that hooks up with a girl and doesn't let go. That's not really a thing people talk about. Versus the girl who hooks up once and just falls in love with you and never leaves you alone. That crazy girl. Yeah, that's a thing.
她用了“迫切”这个词，这很有意思。我在书中指出，如今一个学生能被叫的最糟糕的称呼既不是荡妇，甚至也不是保守的人（尽管这个也挺严重）。而是“绝望”。所以如果规则是我们本该进行无意义的性爱，并且我们要上演所有能让我们维持这种错觉的戏码，哪怕这并不是人们心里的真实感受。那么对他们来说，说“我其实挺喜欢你的”就是违背规则。
And we so desperately don't want to look like that. So when you hook up with someone that you actually really liked, and you really wanted to be with them, and then they don't text you back. And so it's over. That sounds like a terrible place to be in because you are going through hook-up culture to try and find a relationship, but the rules demand that you can't actually ask for one. Yeah. Yeah.
这带有性别色彩：对一个约炮伴侣表现得不感兴趣，比男性的不感兴趣更难以让人相信，哪怕男人们在这方面其实很在行。因此，男性往往会假设所有女性都对和他们建立恋爱关系感兴趣，不管她们是不是真的这么想，这使得男性在约炮后比平时更加冷漠，因为他们假设女孩只是想黏着他们。这就把女性置于这样一种境地：她们试图证明自己不是那种想赖上刚和自己约炮的家伙的人。于是她比平时表现得更加冷漠。而因为规则是“表现得比对方更不在乎”，这就引发了这种向下盘旋的螺旋。
And she used the word desperately, which was interesting. I argue in the book that the worst thing a student can be called these days isn't slut, and it's not even prude, although that one's big one. It's desperate. So if the rule is that we're supposed to be having meaningless sex, and we're enacting all the things that enable us to keep that illusion going, even when that's not how people actually feel. Then it's against the rules for them to say, I actually quite like you. And this is gendered in that, to be disinterested in a hook-up partner, is less believable than men's, even when they are
莉莎，我们刚才讨论了约炮文化可能在校园里对女性不太友好，但从你的书中我也有一种感觉，它可能对男性也不是很友好。确实如此。男人是人，女人也是人，他们有各种各样的需求是约炮文化无法满足的。
actually quite good at this. And so men tend to assume that all women are interested in having a relationship with them, whether they are or not, which makes men even more sort of standoffish after a hookup than they otherwise would be, because they're assuming the girl just wants to get with them. And it puts women in the position of trying to prove that they aren't the kind of person who wants to get with the guy she just hooked up with. And so then she's even more standoffish than she would be otherwise. And because the rule is to care less than the other person, then that creates this downward
约炮文化迎合的是一种刻板的男性形象。有些男人和女人确实是那样的，他们在那种环境中如鱼得水。但大多数学生想要的是不同机遇的组合。如果你去问的话——事实上，男性比女性高出几个百分点——他们会说自己希望能够拥有一段恋爱关系。拥有有意义的关系，拥有善良的有意义的性体验，那是每个人都想要的，当然绝不仅仅是女性。
spiral. We've talked a little bit Lisa about how hook up culture might not be serving women very less than the other person, then that creates this downward spiral. We've talked a little bit Lisa about how hook-up culture might not be serving women very well on campus, but I also get the sense from your book that it might not be serving men very well. It's not. Men are human beings, and so are women, and they have all kinds of different needs that are not served by hookup culture.
所以你在书中写道：约炮文化要求漫不经心，奖励冷酷无情，惩罚善良。男人和女人都享有自由发生性关系的权利，但谁也无法完全自由地去爱。听起来真让人沮丧。是的。这太令人心碎了。当我写这本书时，这是最让我感到悲伤的领悟之一，那就是约炮文化如此强烈地让学生们相信：他们不应该为自己有感情而感到尴尬，不应该为渴望连结而觉得自己软弱。我非常非常佩服这些学生。他们真的很聪明。他们很有洞察力。他们是学生。他们真的很聪明。他们很有洞察力。他们很真诚。他们是很好的人。但这文化太有毒了。
Hookup culture serves a stereotypical idea of a man. There are some guys and some women that are like that, that really do thrive in that. But most students want a different mix of opportunities. And when you ask actually men are more likely than women by a few percentage points to say that they wish they could be in a relationship. Having meaningful relationships, having meaningful sexual
莉莎·韦德是西方学院的社会学家，也是《美国约炮：校园性爱新文化》一书的作者。莉莎，谢谢你今天做客《隐藏的大脑》。这是我的荣幸。本期节目由雷妮·克拉克制作，塔拉·博伊尔编辑。我们的团队包括玛吉·佩曼、珍妮·施密特、雷娜·科恩和克洛伊·康纳利。我们本周的幕后英雄是艾伦·费尔丹克雷斯。艾伦是这个播客的忠实听众，直到最近还是NPR营销团队的成员。
experiences that are kind, that's something that everyone wants, certainly not just women. So you're right in the book that hook up culture, demands carelessness, rewards callousness, and punishes kindness. Both men and women are free to have sex, but neither is entirely free to love. That sounds pretty depressing. Yeah. It's heartbreaking. It was one of the saddest realizations for me when I was writing the book, just how
艾伦真正理解了《隐藏的大脑》的精髓，他的热情体现在他将新听众连接到节目的努力中。他的团队为《隐藏的大脑》设计了一个标志，你可能在社交媒体上见过它，或者在NPR礼品店出售T恤上见过。非常感谢艾伦，祝你一路顺风。如果《隐藏的大脑》曾是你历险或公路旅行的一部分，感谢你带上我们。如果你有朋友或家人在2017年开始旅行，请推荐我们的节目作为他们旅途中的收听材料。
powerfully hook-up culture has convinced students that they should be embarrassed for having feelings and feel weak for wanting connection. And I am very, very impressed by the students. They're really smart. They're very insightful. They're students. They're really smart. They're very insightful. They're earnest. They're wonderful people. But the culture is very toxic.
我是尚卡尔·韦丹塔姆，这是NPR。本集还没有评论。点击文稿中的任何句子即可发表评论。
Lisa Wade is a sociologist at Occidental College and the author of the book, American Hookup, the new culture of sex on campus. Lisa, thanks for joining me on Hidden Brain today. It was my pleasure. This episode was produced by Renee Clark and edited by Tara Boyle. Our team includes Maggie Penman, Jenny Schmidt, Raina Cohen and Chloe Connelly. Our unsung hero this week is Alan Feldancress. Alan's a regular listener to this podcast and until recently was a member of NPR's
Lisa Wade 是西方学院的社会学家，也是《美国约会：校园性爱新文化》一书的作者。Lisa，谢谢你今天来到《隐形大脑》。这是我的荣幸。本集由 Renee Clark 制作，Tara Boyle 编辑。我们的团队包括 Maggie Penman、Jenny Schmidt、Raina Cohen 和 Chloe Connelly。我们本周的无名英雄是 Alan Feldancress。Alan 是本播客的忠实听众，直到最近还是 NPR 的
marketing team. Alan really got what Hidden Brain is all about and his enthusiasm came through in his efforts to connect new listeners to the show. His team developed a logo for Hidden Brain, you may have seen it on social media, or on the t-shirts that are available at the NPR gift shop. Many thanks Alan and Bon Voyage. If Hidden Brain has been a part of your adventures or road trips, thank you for bringing us along. If you friends or family embarking on travels in 2017, please suggest our show as listening material
营销团队成员。Alan 真正理解了《隐形大脑》的真谛，他在努力将新听众与节目联系起来的过程中，表现出了极大的热情。他的团队为《隐形大脑》设计了一个标志，你可能在社交媒体上见过它，或者在 NPR 礼品店出售的 T 恤上见过。非常感谢你，Alan，一路顺风。《隐形大脑》如果曾伴随你的冒险或公路旅行，感谢你带着我们同行。如果你的朋友或家人在 2017 年踏上旅程，请推荐我们的节目作为他们
during their journeys. I'm Shankar Vidhantham, and this is NPR. you There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
旅途中的收听内容。我是 Shankar Vidhantham，这里是 NPR。本集目前还没有评论。点击文稿中的任意句子即可留下评论。